[Music]
it's out of the Academy no they do not I
want to ask you you look at this and
this is really a big night for Netflix
this is their first big movie what does
it mean to be a part of their first big
thing you know the the it's all
experimental you know and the the world
just in general is in a space of
transition right now and I was excited
to just take this leap with Netflix I
got to ask you this where is your family
calls every with you but now that your
children are all working your wife is
constantly working that they just
abandon you Christmas is the time when
we all come together we've been
scattered to the four corners all of
this year so Christmas is the to come
together and everybody's coming back
together yeah yeah we're getting there
together and Jaden is Jaden is getting
very serious around about Christmas it
used to be just Jada you know and now
Jaden is starting to like yearn for the
Christmas time he got for jamas with
footies for Christmas like he's taking
it too serious and I'm you know so we
just we need some family time to like so
he can deal with that
and he gets you in some pajamas with
hoodies see here's the deal so for the
last probably 20 years like Jada has
been like that raving loony about
Christmas like she goes really far
really really far with Christmas and up
until now it's been like us against her
for Christmas just to keep a little
family sanity around Christmas but now
Jaden is starting to flip to the other
side so I'm concerned and my family is
gonna go real christmas and wacky yeah
[Music]